[Musique]
c'est pas facile de t'annoncer south là
alors je crois que je vais aller droit
au but maman et moi on sait par mon
grand alors c'est vraiment fini genre
100% fini c'est un signe l'objet du
litige non résolus concerne les droits
de garde pour le chien de race aussi 3
kg morgane a fait part de son extrême à
prudence est de mise
la cour décide donc d'attribuer la garde
complète à madame moubarak les jeunes
bat pour toi ouais c'est et comment tu
vas faire ça c'est j'en ai aucune idée
et le processus de deuil tu en es où ° 2
colère qu'il est une brique ou wesley
est au bord de l'abyme de la dépression
nerveuse cette nouvelle version de clay
ne marchera jamais
[Musique]
projet
c'est bien mieux sorti d'après elle me
manque aussi venir qui dit j'ai besoin
d'un super plan mais un cadenas tonkar
et meurt tout seul je sais que les
choses n'ont pas été très normal
dernièrement
ça arrive mais c'est rare qu'elles le
soient pas prêts j'ai un plan mais il
faut que vous mettiez
peut-être que ce serait bien pour
essayer on se retrouvait tous
[Musique]
sympa non je sais je sais il devient
impatient j'ai juste une question
[Musique]